et avec nous pour en débattre
yves contassot membre d'europe écologie
les verts à ses côtés stéphane pelé
vice-président du mouvement la france
vraiment bonsoir messieurs bonsoir à
tous les deux merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france donc on l'aura
compris évidemment pas mal de crispation
dans la cour de l'elysée d'ailleurs
partout à la plupart des syndicats ne
sont pas très enthousiastes à l'idée de
discuter de cette réforme des retraites
alors que plane toujours la menace
épidémique
on va avant de vous faire réagir les
gouttes et laurent berger le patron de
la cfdt qui menacent même de mobiliser
ses troupes à la rentrée prendre des
décisions aujourd'hui c'est plus que
prématurée ça serait même hors de propos
dans la période que nous sommes en train
de vivre je crois que je crois même que
avoir dit qu'il y avait un risque social
et démocratique
un stéphane telle est en tout cas un
relèvement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite dont ne veut pas laurent berger
c'est vraiment pas le moment inscrit un
risque social et démocratique le
gouvernement doit se lancer malgré tout
ce que je dirai simplement ce soir c'est
que un président ne devrait pas faire ça
d'une manière générale un président ne
devrait pas mener une réforme tambour
battant six mois avant une consultation
majeur une consultation nationale et à
président ne devrait pas non plus ne pas
réformer ce qu'il a fait pendant cette
période
donc où il était à la tête du pays
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
très probablement il ya une toute autre
méthode à adopter par contre je dois le
dire est très probablement c'est pour ça
que vous avez parlé d'un face à face ce
soir même si ici je suis au nom d'un
mouvement plutôt représentative des
citoyens et qui n'est pas sur une
attitude partisane mais évidemment moi
je représente plutôt le camp de ceux qui
veulent une réforme tout simplement
parce que le système actuel est injuste
le système actuel permet à des
professions on va dire protéger à près
de 50 de régimes spéciaux de vivre une
retraite relativement apaisé tranquille
et tant mieux pour eux ils l'ont bien
mérité mais surtout ça n'attire aucun
jeune dans la voie professionnelle
veut pas qu'un jeune français un jeune
qui s'engage sur le marché du travail
s'engagent simplement au vu du système
de retraites qu'il connaîtra dans
quelques décennies tout ça était valable
dans une toute autre époque
à l'époque où il fallait attirer les
gens sur le monde du travail vous le
savez les régimes spéciaux par exemple
celui de la sncf a été créée par des
sociétés privées dans les années 20
parce qu'elle voulait attirer des jeunes
en france partout pour poser des rails
c'était des métiers très difficile tout
ça n'existe plus nous sommes plutôt dans
une période où malheureusement il ya
beaucoup moins d'actifs par rapport au
nombre de retraités donc il faut
répartir maintenant autrement le fruit
du travail et c'est pour ça que je pense
que aller vers un régime universel est
une bonne chose mais par contre
s'engager dans un débat est peut-être je
vais je vais l'essayer de contagion que
je salue donc prendre la parole et je
reviendrai peut-être sur la méthode tout
à l'heure mais je pense qu'il faut une
toute autre méthode avec notamment une
méthode de concertation des français qui
fera l'objet d' ailleurs d'un grand
débat pendant la période de campagne
électorale
on va revenir évidemment sur la méthode
mais aussi sur le fond du débat ce qu'on
en a vraiment besoin de cette réforme
est tout d'abord sur l'opportunité de la
mener avant la fin du quinquennat il
faut contassot est-ce que emmanuel
macron doit se lancer on rappelle quand
même que c'était l'une de ses promesses
principal de campagne on l'a vu sur le
dossier des retraites
emmanuel macron a voulu passer en force
avec l'adoption de sa réforme avec ce
qu'on appelle le 49-3 c'est à dire
l'impossibilité pour les parlementaires
de s'exprimer et de voter donc on n'est
pas du tout dans la concertation dans
l'élaboration d'un projet nécessaire
sans doute mais pas comme il est prévu
tiers qu'en fait c'est pas un aliment en
améliorant le sort des gens qui est
proposé c'est au contraire une baisse
générale si on veut s'aligner vers le
bas supprimant les régimes spéciaux qui
pour certains sont effectivement plus
favorable que le régime général à tous
l'au delà et deuxièmement avec et là on
le voit bien avec ça ce débat sur le
report de l'âge de la retraite de l'âge
yann c'est de faire baisser le coût de
la retraite il ne s'en cache pas c'est
son seul objectif est un discours assez
scandaleux d'ailleurs sur les retraités
sont riches quand on regarde le minimum
vieillesse
je m'appelle le minimum vieillesse 900
euros par mois
c'est ça et riche le la retraite moyenne
en france moins de 1300 euros nets par
mois et pour les femmes c'est 32 % de
moins que pour les hommes
c'est sale et riche et ses chiffres ce
sont les chiffres officiels de l'insee
du conseil d'orientation des retraites
qui dit lui même que l'on va avoir
modification du rapport et le nombre de
retraités qui va s'améliorer dans les
années à venir et donc on fait la
proposition enfin c'est ce que faire
monsieur makrout purement conjoncturelle
il faut lire le rapport du cor il est
extrêmement intéressant parce qu'il dit
lui même qu'il n'ya pas eu de
dégradation de la couverture des
retraites malgré la crise économistes
pour plein de raisons
et donc on voit bien que tout ça est
purement dans la même logique toujours
réduire réduire réduire le pouvoir
d'achat au sens large le pouvoir de
vivre des personnes en france
avec cette espèce de discours classique
il faut réduire tout ce qui vient du
public et favoriser le privé
n'oubliez pas que derrière ce voile à
toutes les compagnies d'assurance qui
pousse en dix ans sortons du régime des
retraites tel qu'il existe en france
depuis près d'un siècle maintenant 80
ans pour passer à un régime de type
américain régime d'assurance
individuelle c'est ça qui est derrière
ces réponses il faut pas je crois que
pour pour répondre à une question d'une
telle portée parce qu'on le dit toujours
c'est la mère des réformes cette réforme
des retraites tout simplement parce que
on vit plus longtemps et on aspire à une
retraite heureuse et donc évidemment que
c'est un problème essentiel dans la vie
de tous les français mais pour aborder
ces questions là ces réformes là il ne
faut pas exagérer
d'ailleurs yves contassot lui même vient
de dire pourquoi il faut réformer tout
simplement parce que le minet
vieillesse est bien trop bas parce que
les gens rentraient dans la carrière
tard avec des études très longues se
retrouvent un niveau de retraite trop
faible parce que des femmes par exemple
qu'ils ont une carrière interrompue à
plusieurs reprises se retrouver avec des
retraites est faible très faible donc
c'était toute une série d'avancées
possible avec une réforme des retraites
mais pour réformer cela il fallait aller
vers un nouveau système et c'est pour ça
que moi j'apprécie les grandes
comment dire les grandes envolées de
monsieur contassot je pense que nous
pourrions être d'accord sur un certain
nombre de principes mais pas sur le fait
qu' on ne peut pas maintenir le système
tel qu'il est et c'est pour ça que nous
la force vraiment que le ministère des
situation qui donne un mouvement
national nous faisons une proposition
simple puisque nous rentrons dans une
période de campagne électorale
nous proposons que ce débat des
retraites fasse l'objet d'une grande
consultation nationale et que les
décisions ne soient prises que par le
prochain président la pub que ce soit
celui actuel qui se succéderaient
lui-même ou bien une présidente un
président et je pense que ça changerait
beaucoup de choses que les français
aient toutes les informations et en
particulier et à décider sur les trois
problèmes majeurs
doit-on allonger l'âge de la retraite
doit-on changer le niveau de la pension
ou doit-on contribuer plus tout au long
de sa vie voilà vers quoi on pourrait
aller avec une consultation nationale
qui serait donc faite lors du prochain
mandat présidentiel
mais vous le voyez il y a un réel
blocage est ce que vous avez entendu ce
qu'ont dit les responsables syndicaux
un responsable syndical s'est rendu donc
au palais présidentiel en disant nous ne
voulons pas de réformes dans ce mandat
pas plus que dans le prochain on voit
très bien que les syndicats qui
représentent à peine 8% des personnes en
activité compte bloqué le système
donc à part peut-être certains avec un
esprit plus d'ouverture comme on peut
saluer notamment l'attitude de monsieur
laurent berger voilà donc je pense qu'il
faut faire très attention
70% d'abstention non récente élection le
al des syndicats qui ne représentent que
10% il faut faire attention que ce ne
soit pas les personnes les moins
représentative qui prennent les
décisions
alors avant de vous faire essayer de
consommation va écouter monsieur oui on
va juste pardonnez moi vous allez
pouvoir répondre à ses fans pelé mais il
ya quand même un syndicat évidemment
peut-être pas celui auquel vous faisiez
référence qui est d'accord avec
l'opportunité d'une réforme évidemment
c'est le medef je vous propose d'écouter
un geoffroy roux de bézieux
nous on est favorable à une réforme des
retraites qu'ils soient qui traîne la
seule mesure qui soit vraiment
significatif qui est la mesure d'âge
donc le passage de l'âge légal de 62 à
63 64 65
mais on s'interroge sur le bon timing
surtout avec le variant delta et la
recrudescence des présidents du medh
afin qu'ils s'interrogent quand même lui
aussi sur le timing mais voilà thiviers
en gros le passage de l'âge légal de 62
à 63 64 voire 65 et est inéluctable pour
lui il compte ainsi on imagine que vous
partagez pas cet avis il n'empêche c'est
vrai que par rapport au reste de
l'europe la france serait en contraste
oui alors monsieur roux de bézieux ne
manque pas d'air quand on voit les
parachutes dorés que tous ces grands
patrons s'attribuent à coups de millions
de millions payés sur le dos des
entreprises
venir dire que les salariés doivent
travailler plus longtemps c'est vraiment
d'un cynisme est d'un niveau aussi les
petites entreprises
vous voulez qu'on regarde les
répartition des revenus en france entre
les patrons notamment des grandes
entreprises mais pas que et puis les
salariés on peut s'amuser à ça mais je
peux vous garantir le medef ne sortira
pas grandie et alors pourquoi
pousse-t-il évidemment à ça mais qu'ils
commencent par regarde 50 % des
personnes de plus de 60 ans ne travaille
pas ne travaille pas il n'y a pas
d'emploi pour les seniors et on va leur
dire avant déjà vous n'avez pas d'emploi
mais vous allez attendre deux ans de
plus pour toucher la retraite c'est ça
l'amélioration
situation si vous voulez avoir à nouveau
alors dg légion d'une puissance 10
continuons comme ça c'est vraiment de la
provocation
et si monsieur rugby dans le deuxième
quinquennat au prochain quinquennat
c'est pas par hasard c'est que il sait
très bien que ce n'est pas acceptable
socialement et que dans la situation
économique délicate que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui avec ce risque en plus de
quatrième vague il n'a aucune envie qui
est le feu sur le plan social à la
rentrée
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils demandent le
report en espérant qu'après avril 2022
ça ira mieux et qu'il pourra passer en
force alors monsieur collègues quand on
dit les syndicats qui représentent 8%
monsieur macron il a fait vingt et un
peu plus de 20% à la présidentielle donc
dire que c'est plus démocratique quand
on a fait 20 % que 8%
j'en suis pas convaincu moi je pense
qu'effectivement il peut y avoir un
grand nenê je propose justement que les
français se déterminent sur cette
réforme majeure
ces questions peuvent différer de zéro
et d'ailleurs pour employer une formule
de notre présidente aurélie gros je
dirais on ne gouverne pas contre son
peuple
pas plus le président que les syndicats
et je pense qu'il faudra rendre la
parole aux français dans ce type de
réformes et un nom de consultation de
concertation puis ensuite un système
soit référendaire peut-être vous n'y
serait pas favorable et en tous les cas
un système qui fait que le président
nouvellement élu aurait toute légitimité
cette fois ci pour mener cette réforme
voilà c'est russell donner aux
citoyennes
on a vu qu'on tient une conférence
citoyenne que les citoyens ont la parole
que fait le gouvernement
il s'assoit dessus complètement donc
pourquoi demain prendrait-il des
décisions justes garantir par avance
qu'il n'écoutera pas les conclusions
merci en tout cas tous les deux ça je ne
le crois pas à ça je ne crois pas que
oui allez vous allez voir que la
citoyenneté va rester l'acte fort des
démons
à venir une citoyenneté partagée merci
beaucoup stefano lai contassot d'avoir
été avec nous en direct pour ceux ci
annemasse en direction rt france